so here's some quotes I'd like to read
you okay
on blowing 100 million dollars quote it
happens when
I know cats that blew double that that's
the second response it continues it can
happen to anyone
I don't think you could have it anywhere
[Music]
all right what's up we got a fun episode
here so we're gonna do we're gonna play
a little game
and the game is that
Sam I want me and you to go back and
forth kind of like we do when we hang
out if we were just back in the day when
we both used to drink it drink a beer or
two and we would just try to entertain
each other sort of one-up each other
with stories and um I'll tell you a
story a business story that I think is
pretty juicy you tell me a business
story that you think is pretty juicy and
we're gonna see who we're gonna we're
gonna measure these uh you know to see
who can tell the juiciest backstory
behind celebrity Brands now I texted you
last night I go celebrity brands but not
the celebrity part the juicy backstory
and that's all we said to each other
like for example uh we don't use this
one but what's the uh Kylie Cosmetics uh
Kendall what's her name Kylie Jenner
Kylie Jenner she has this lipstick
company that does hundreds of millions
in Revenue she's obviously not the one
like running the show she had to partner
with someone number two a behind the
scenes person we're gonna talk all about
behind the scenes people who is that
number two how did they make this come
about how do they get the celebrity
partnership what made it work versus
many others that failed
um who are these sharks that are that
are behind the scenes who's the number
two we're go so I dare say we're going
number two today and we're doing it live
with all of you all right
we rake it from raised to Grape with the
wine being a 10 out of 10 grippy nine
out of ten I don't actually know what's
the in between stages of Raisin and
grape but is it juicy like a prune like
a raisin like a grape or is it straight
wine that's how juicy this is Juicy
Juice uh boxes that's how that's how
good these can be all right so dude I I
have a I have a low juicy story I wanted
to ask you or ask your opinion about
before we get into this yeah go for it
this listen this weekend I went to Miami
for this Hampton thing we went like
lobster diving it was awesome I stayed
at a very fancy hotel I'm not gonna name
the hotel yet because I want to see I
wait to the end of the story I was
working out you know those cable
machines like it's like uh cable
machines were used at Raw like use the
rod to like change the weights at the
bottom and you know how there's like a
2.5 pound weight that's usually at the
top that's like adjustable yeah I I was
fixing the weight and the Machine was
broken apparently I didn't notice it was
broken and that two-point Rod that 2.5
pound weight fell on my finger I have
got my finger looks like a great can you
see that is it all purple yeah I can see
it all right the question is is what
type of petty Court do we go to about
this is this just like
is this just like a free stay like do I
get my money back is it like I want my
money back plus like another free stay
well you you have to find a way to talk
where you're waving that like you got to
change your gestures so like you got to
have like this Obama Style Just
gesticular you know motions when you're
talking because you need to see the
manager that the manager needs to see
the finger and the finger I mean you're
not you're not trying to wave it in
their face it's just you just need to do
one of those where you point at it
you're like
what what am I supposed to do about this
I mean yeah I need something for this
this doesn't happen this is off your
property sure did yeah look if I go to a
fancy hotel I expect a fancy gym right
not like with the screws come out of the
freaking equipment so I my finger looks
like a grape right now right it's like
you know it's one of those injuries that
isn't you don't do anything with a
broken finger right you do nothing but
God damn it hurts this is like when
Willis Reed limped into game seven of
the NBA finals from the tunnel and the
crowd goes crazy they said no it's not
possible he couldn't possibly be playing
with that injury that's how people
playing this podcast today should feel
about your ability to
persevere through that Intrigue I'm a
blogger bro I'm a I'm a tweeter I tweet
and also I can't exercise now for a week
and that's why I make a living is with
my seven out of 10 body
yeah that's how a cat feels when they
lose one of their lives
so anyway maybe I'll have an update to
the story maybe I'll get a free stay to
blank Hotel name
but we'll see if I can persevere with
this just aching finger but I think we I
think we could do it do you want to go
through your best okay so there's this
woman named Emma greed do you know that
name
no I'm agree first of all destined to be
famous with a name like that Emma greed
agreed like greed like money greed yeah
but it's g-r-e-d-e says a little bit
like got her own got her own spin on it
so um she is the business shark behind a
bunch of the Kardashian Brands so she
was a founding partner in skims the
multi-billion dollar shapewear brand for
Kim Kardashian her husband is the CEO of
that by the way uh so the the couple is
behind this the next one is
um she co-founded good American the
jeans brand that's massive that probably
does 300 million a year in Revenue
um so you know uh with Khloe Kardashian
so she that's how she broke into that
and then with Kris Jenner she goes to
the mom and she co-founds safely a
plant-based cleaning product brand
um with her and Chrissy Teigen and so
this woman she's so impressive
um if you've ever seen her a lot of
people now have seen her because I think
she's on Shark Tank this season so if
you like are into that form of like you
know uh entertainment if you've seen her
she's so she's super polished so she's
she's this woman who's half black half
white super good looking British accent
and an absolute Savage in terms of
business this is what I've gathered from
watching a bunch of interviews of hers
by the way did you see the recent Rays
for skims I think skims raised 200
million dollars at a three billion
evaluation yeah and she owns oh my God
she owned eight percent of that I don't
know after dilution what she owns but
she owned eight percent of that so her
stake in skims alone is basically a
multi-hundred million dollar stake
um forget about good American where she
was like you know it was her idea she
was the the kind of the the CEO she's
the she's the operator behind that so
here's you want to hear her story it's
uh yeah it's pretty good so she's um
she's daughter of a single mom which is
the start of every great uh
entrepreneurial Story by the way uh
second thing she she basically is like a
hustler which is Young she's got a paper
route she's like working at a deli she's
just working all kinds of like blue
collar jobs and she's like okay you know
what I want to make it in fashion and so
she goes to the London College of
fashion and she's 14 15 years old she's
already like interning at Gucci she's
like hustling her way into like these
like low-level internships at fashion
brands and she drops out because she's
like dude I'm hustling on the weekends
and after school like these fashion
shows or in my internship I'm networking
with all these people
I feel like I'm learning way more and
building a way more valuable asset which
is my network outside of school than I
am inside of school so she drops out
and she starts working for a couple of
like she works for like a a Runway
company and then she starts her own
agency she's like oh okay here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna create this
agency called ITB uh she's 26 years old
I think at the time and she's like she's
been hustling in the fashion industry so
now she's got connections so she's like
hey let me just be a DOT connector and
so she's like I'm going to connect all
these fashion brands want to do collabs
with influencers and celebrities and
I'll create an agency that does that for
them so oh you know the way she kind of
got her break was Calvin mccleine wants
to do a campaign for their new launch of
whatever the new thing is she sources 70
different models and influencers for
them signs all the contracts one of
those people is Kendall Jenner to do
that deal she meets Kris Jenner and so
she becomes somewhat friendly like
they've done a couple of campaigns
together she's booked her out she has a
little bit of respect so here's what she
does then she's like okay this model of
connecting like using kind of celebrity
influencers is working for these brands
but they kind of do it in a inauthentic
way it's like only transactions like
when when you need the when you need
them to promote X product they show up
and then they disappear she's like no no
I think we should have a story and a
celebrity at the beginning of these
Brands and so she has this idea for good
American a denim brand that is I I don't
know if you're how familiar you are with
it but it's basically like their thing
is it's kind of like all sizes it's sort
of like body positive early on and she
was like you know we're gonna have we're
gonna carry like from size zero to size
whatever like 24 or something like that
imagine that pitch to one of the
Kardashians so it worked like she's like
I know but like look here's here's the
thing Chloe
she's like why me well Chloe you might
want to sit down for a second
you have to say one of those things like
I'm not racist but it's like uh
yeah I'm not trying to be offensive but
you're the perfect fit for this brand
I don't know which one is Chloe but
they're all like obviously fit and
skinny but she maybe she's like the
she's the one who kind of went up and
down and wait she was like At first she
was like the big the bigger one of the
sisters and she like had these like
sisters who were like you know size zero
that was insecurity and she got super
super skinny but then she like kind of
you know
imagine that conversations with like
Weight Watchers or like one of these
Brands comes to you you know what I mean
or like I'm honored you know
how Jamie Lee Curtis is the spokesperson
for that yogurt company that makes you
poop regularly uh what's it called yeah
I don't know which one
it's it's like a yogurt that like
elderly people are supposed to eat so it
makes them go to the bathroom like on a
regular basis like a message like look
we're gonna call it oops I cracked my
pants and we we want you to be the face
a you know what I mean
who cares I I don't care you know
there's no problem with this
the uh so she pitches Kris Jenner she
goes Chris I bumped she bumped into her
fashion she's like I got an idea for a
brand and she was expecting like look I
know you guys get hundreds of offers but
she's like I've already seen how much of
a hustler you are she's like I observed
the way you operate like I already kind
of like kind of uh co-sign this you
should just meet with Chloe directly see
if Chloe likes it if she likes it heard
it already has my blessing so she meets
with Chloe Chloe's in and they basically
start this brand
uh brand has scaled up now into the
hundreds of millions it's one of the the
fastest growing denim Brands the jeans
brands from there she then approaches
Kim and she's like Kim we should do a
shapewear brand and her husband who's
also in the fashion industry became the
the kind of the day-to-day person
because she was busy with good American
but they together create skims which
becomes a multi-billion dollar shapewear
brand then she does this one with with
her uh with with the mom as well
and so I just found this fascinating
what this family is doing so they
basically have a hold code the Glee
family what's that the Glebe family the
greed family or so James greed and
emigrid so they basically have a hold
code called Popular Ventures or
something a popular culture or something
like that like he also did Brady the
clothing brand with Tom Brady so they're
spitting up these fashion and and
consumer product brands with a plus
celebrities and they've built they're on
the Forbes list now these guys have a
like you know 400 500 million dollar net
worth just co-founding these with uh
with the Kardashian family and with uh
you know Tom Brady and whatnot so
impressive to fold that off behind the
scenes uh and what's frame they have
another one called frame is that a
fashion brand that the husband started
that they sell like 300 t-shirts I I
don't get it but like you know have you
seen what they look like this husband
and wife couple it's hard to like them
because they're so good looking they're
like perfect yeah
like they're so good looking they're
both they both look like it I was
definitely reading it and I was like
yeah but they probably don't have a good
relationship I was like trying to find
some crap
cholesterol issues you never know
nobody's got it all yeah yeah but this
guy probably broke both fingers not even
just one
yeah they they're pretty perfect like
these guys look like influencers
themselves and so all right so where do
you put where do you rank on the juicy
scale Emma and Jen's Greed from prune to
wine
uh it's in the middle so they're
incredibly impressive this is amazing
that they do this it's what's even more
amazing is that like so John Rockefeller
had this famous uh phrase where he would
uh when he was trying to buy other
companies he was like look you should
you should join my oil company I make so
much money and they're like no you can't
make more he goes look I know I make
money I make money in ways that you
can't even dream about you have no idea
how much money I make and that's exactly
what the Kardashians are like this good
America that's just this little thing
I've never even heard of that makes
hundreds of millions of dollars that's
amazing
um but there's no drama here so I'm
gonna put it like right in the middle a
prune does a prune have juice in it I
think it does we're gonna give it a
prune prune's the lowest it's principle
raisin is the middle I think we're going
with then it's a razor this is a raisin
there's there's no drama here I need
some drama but this is these guys are
amazing they're a perfect couple I
understand I tried to start with like
you know raised from a single mother
because that was really the only like
story of of not just badass winning
um you know but uh The Humble origin
story but I agree with you there was uh
like if you Google her name there's like
a picture of her and Khloe Kardashian
posing with I guess one of their brands
and they look like models like I was
like is this the founder or or a model
they look like models this reminds me of
I actually didn't do uh research on this
guy but it reminds me he is also in the
Kardashian sphere but have you heard of
Brian Lee
The Honest Company guy
yeah so Brian Lee so do you remember who
that's so weird do you remember Robert
Shapiro I don't know if you would
remember him lawyer who is that the
lawyer okay the lawyer so basically
Robert Shapiro was one of the guys I
think he defended O.J Simpson that's
what he was famous for do you remember
that's their dad right
no so this is where it gets uh funny so
Robert so the Kardashian family is
famous because one of the Kardashians I
forget the name the dad who's who's uh
died he defended O.J Simpson along with
Robert Shapiro
and Robert Shapiro
you know he's a lawyer Big Shot probably
a smart guy he ends up partnering with
Brian Lee Brian Lee's this this guy did
in 2001 so Brian Lee was only in his uh
early 20s he goes hey I have this idea
for this legal company but I need a
celebrity to be the face of it so
somehow he call or he actually cold call
Robert Shapiro and said hey do you want
to be a partner on my new legal company
and he's like yeah come to my office
let's talk about it and he Woos them it
works out well that company is now
called LegalZoom and it's a I don't know
if it's quite a billion dollar company
but it's in that range it's a really
successful company and so Robert Shapiro
and Brian Lee were like hey this worked
who the else do you want to do it with
and Roberto's like well I got these
friends you know I worked with their dad
the Kardashians what if we worked with
them and so he does it again and he
creates this company called ShoeDazzle
which doesn't end up working out
amazingly and it was actually pretty
early this was in 2009 with Kim
Kardashian he partnered with her and it
was like a subscription shoe company
didn't work out that well and his third
company he did called The Honest Company
which I think they went public yeah do
they go public yeah they are public and
so he partnered with Jessica Alba for
that and he ended up selling like I
think 30 million dollars worth of shares
before it even went public now he's
doing it again where he co-founded
another company with Derek Jeter and
it's a digital sports card collecting
company so this guy Brian Lee has been
doing the same thing very similar to the
greed family of like in the Kardashian
sphere and just like being the operator
and uh he's a pretty amazing guy so
Brian Lee's an interesting guy as well
dude we could pull up honest Company's
stock by the way
hammered absolutely absolutely what's it
at now when it debuted in 2021 is that
20 share is currently at a dollar forty
it is now only worth 130 million dollars
market cap is it really I think they do
like 100 million in sales so it's I
guess it's trading for one times Revenue
ouch it's kind of great brand I wonder
uh who's gonna buy that I think I feel
like that's a great Target to buy yeah
it's an interesting one but this guy
Brian Lee's been doing this stuff we'll
put him in the same category though
that's only a middle one when you're
with the Kardashians it's kind of a
stack deck yeah it's a stack deck
um all right you you do one all right I
have one so this one's kind of uh
popular right now but there's a really
interesting story behind it so virtual
dining company or is that what it's
called sorry virtual virtual dining
Concepts so basically a couple years ago
Mr Beast launched Beast burger and the
idea that I think they actually do they
tell us on the Pod I think he mentioned
this in the Pod right his manager uh
yeah I think so he was basically like we
had this idea and we went from like idea
to executing in like such a short amount
of time which was a huge mistake I think
he said they did it in like 60 days or
90 days something crazy but they
partnered with this company called
virtual dining Concepts and they launch
this thing two years later now it's like
a show so Mr Beast is tweeting uh
and he's actually deleted a bunch of the
tweets but he's basically said like this
company has ruined my reputation because
the burger sucks the quality control
sucks now they are both suing each other
so that alone is a story but that's not
even the interesting part the
interesting part is the guy behind it so
the guy behind it his name is Robert
Earl so Robert Earl is interesting
because in his early 20s he started a
company that was just it was just a
restaurant I think it was like a
medieval restaurant have you ever like
seen those on on like movies no but
every time I would go to Vegas I would
stay at what's that castle one called
the medieval castle it's like uh that
terrible hotel that's where I almost
stayed well he started this thing I
think it was called beef eater and it
was in England he's from England and it
was called beef eater and it was like a
medieval themed restaurant and so he
starts growing that and after a handful
of years like 10 years he sells it makes
like 60 million dollars and he's like
all right what what what next and so his
next thing is Planet Hollywood do you
remember Planet Hollywood of course so
Planet Hollywood was a restaurant
concept where it was like we're gonna go
big with all the stars so it was big
stars were Bruce Willis
um Sylvester Stallone Arnold
Schwarzenegger and then like Demi Moore
Cindy Crawford he had like all the stars
like aligned with this restaurant and he
gave them all equity and goes you guys
are going to be a face we're gonna do
Planet Hollywood you go to the
restaurant and there's going to be like
Wax figures of all the celebrities
whatever it was a big deal at the time
and he expands it and eventually goes
public but they expand way too quickly
and they eventually go bankrupt but it's
still like it's kind of like a famous
failure in that it actually probably
could have worked but they expanded too
quickly then he keeps doing this
though so he eventually buys yeah stop
he's a concept junkie this guy he's a
concept this guy he's a concept
brainstorming with this guy like this
guy would this guy would would not stop
I feel like yeah I gotta be I need to
get in a room with Robert Earl and I
need to have a brainstorm
well he's really interesting and so now
he's got this thing I think it's called
um uh look up uh Earl Enterprises so
he's got this thing now where he owns
um they own like 30 different
restaurants now and it does something
like 500 600 million dollars a year in
revenue and some of the brands are a
chicken restaurant with Guy Fieri he
owns uh do you remember uh you know uh
Balducci like Italian sandwiches and
like pasta restaurants yeah for too
cheap it's like better than Applebee's a
little bit you know they're like they're
really better than Applebee's is the bar
we've got to maintain vigorously for all
of our guns yeah that's like the thing
like none of them are like crazy fancy
but they're all like you know it's like
25 a meal type of thing but he owns a
ton of them and so he's in all not all
of them but many of them have a
celebrity behind them and so he gets
this idea when ghost kitchens start
popping up with Uber and doordash starts
popping up and so he gets his son to
help co-found this new company with them
and that's what virtual dining is and so
he has one with um bar stool where it's
like pardon part of my cheesesteak
part of my Cheesesteak it's a
Cheesesteak uh business and then he
decides to do the same thing except this
time he does it with Mr Beast burger or
Mr uh it's called Mr Beast burger or
beast burger and it takes off but then
obviously they have the their their
issues but he has still done it with a
ton of people so he's done it with
Mariah Carey so he has Mariah's cookies
he started with rapper Tyga which is
crazy to me that Tyga is even relevant
but I think by the way how does he have
that much pull well Tyga dated one of
the Kardashian girls so maybe that's how
I don't know you can walk into my house
right now and I would say Hey sir what's
your name I would not know yeah who Tyga
is
um yeah it's weird so he has Tiger bites
they have part of my cheesecake I need
to meet somebody who's just eating Tiger
bites like who are the who are the
customers think of my thing yeah yeah
yeah they are strong and you know I
think I think he's working on Hoobastank
Hoagies uh that's gonna be the next one
yeah I don't know what the deal is with
Tyga but he's done this a whole bunch of
times where he has this like pretty
massive Empire and right now he's being
sued and uh
he's they said in the comment or they
made a comment and they're like look
like a lot of people are complaining
about Beast Burgers but he goes That's
just normal like when you serve all
these people uh and he's like look look
at all of our restaurants people
complain look it's normal people
complain about all our
but
but the guy's got like a ton of stuff
going on so he owns a casino he owns a
Aladdin Resort and Casino and lost on
the Las Vegas Strip he still owns Planet
Hollywood and they're trying to make it
uh come back a little bit or he owns a
couple of them he owns a soccer team
that Everton soccer team have you heard
of that yeah of course uh yeah and him
and his wife live in a 25 000 square
foot mansion in Florida I mean the guy's
a baller and if you if you Google him
he's like this old looking guy who kind
of wears tacky shirts but he looks like
a like a blast to hang out with he has a
TV show now where he's like it's almost
like uh what's that TV show called like
uh everyone feeds Phil where it's just
like a dorky guy just like talking to
restaurant owners and like learning
about the local Cuisine he's got one of
those things so he seems like that's his
show then that's not a show it's like
it's very it's very similar to that but
this guy um dude these people who have
these like sprawling Empires where
they're like yeah I own uh you know
Planet Hollywood but then I got this uh
I have this like you know juice brand
and then I have this hotel over here and
then I got like I own the soccer team
um
is that who you want to be uh I'm
curious because I think some people
really want that I'm not sure that I
would want that that seems like just a
lot of knowledge
um it seems like a lot yeah like it
seems like is that a goal of yours or I
definitely respect it from the farm but
I don't think I want to be that that guy
I think owning a sports team would be
cool but I don't want to own like 500
restaurants so like he owns I don't know
if you've even heard of any of these
Asian street eats The Breakfast Club uh
uh berducci's I've heard of that Brio
Italian Grill Bravo Italian Kitchen
Chicken guy that's Guy Fieri's two J's
Cafe Hollywood have you heard of any of
these no not really
they're all like restaurants that have
like 10 or 20 locations and like
hopefully each location makes like five
million dollars and it's like highly
profitable another guy who does this in
the same similar category is uh Tillman
for Tita do you know who that is you
probably know him because he owns uh
Houston Rockets I think so he I read
this interview with him and he goes I
think I am one of the largest companies
in America that is fully owned by one
person so he owns 100
of the Fertitta Enterprises and it does
something like 4 billion in Revenue 1
million 1 billion in ebitda he owns like
all these kind of you know and some I
guess nice stuff he owns like some
steakhouses maybe like Ruth Chris I
think he owns but then he owns like
Bubba Gump Shrimp and stuff like that
um but some of these restaurant Brands
where it's like 30 50 a meal apparently
they must be really profitable because
I've read about a few of these guys
including Robert Earl I've read about
Tillman for Tita so I don't know I guess
it works but it seems like a pain in the
ass to deal with all these types of
people
yeah uh let's move on to the next one
um let's what's that one oh yeah we
gotta rank that one on the juicy scale
I'm gonna give it uh
I think that might also be a raisin
um partly out of Revenge and partly
because uh
this guy owns a bunch of
like mid-tier things and so I feel like
I can't possibly rank him above I I
don't want to eat at any of his products
let's put it that way
oh you know yeah I do think that but I
you know wait did you go to but didn't
you go to Chuck E Cheese's this weekend
I did not wish I wish I had uh did not I
thought you said you were taking your
kids there you're thinking of someone
else I went puppy golf uh at this dude
it's hilarious these guys opened up a
pup they just took a parking lot
and then like a husband and wife just
sort of had a plywood built a few holes
and they just charge you ten dollars to
walk in that area the of the parking lot
and they'll give you a club and my kids
love it and we go there like you know
like twice a month it's kind of this
insane like uh business plan that makes
no sense I think that makes tons of
sense I mean there's just no like it's
putting without the green you're putting
on concrete and trying to get it oh
there's there's no there's not even Turf
no Turf oh there's a little bit of turf
but it's like the whole thing is very
like and all things like made of
concrete so you know it's not a great
not a great look yikes all right what do
you got all right
um I'm gonna do one that actually we've
we did I was trying to do research for
this and the best breakdown of this
business
was our own podcast like two years ago
but the fact that I had forgot it means
that everybody forgot it I'm gonna I'm
gonna talk about guthy ranker so
these Legends these are the Geniuses
behind a bunch of celebrity things uh
let me pull up my notes here so
um backstory for these guys including
one of my favorite books which one
if they can grow Rich well yes exactly
so okay so here's the here's the the way
that the the business works so Guthrie
ranker so um
one of the guys guthy his last name's
guthy he's he has a business that's
basically audio cassette tape um copies
so you have a you have an audio tape you
want to make 10 000 copies to sell your
music or whatever he makes the 10 000. I
think it was even called like audio tape
duplication Enterprise or some like
that and uh it's a okay business but
then suddenly he gets a call from a guy
by the way I love names like that which
lets us start bringing that back I'm
sick of the like cute that ends in
l y you know like tapely yeah I mean I
want Hampton audio yeah why isn't it a
bunch of dudes talking about their
feelings
I tried to make Hampton a little bit
like uh Jordan Belfort named his company
stratman Oakmont Jordan Belford's the uh
waffle washer guy they're like that's
who you want to model yourself it was
like why'd you do that he's like I don't
know like I just thought of these two
words and it sounded like an official
thing and I was like I gotta like that
uh but I do prefer I do like like
audio tape Enterprises
exactly
[Music]
software is the worst have you heard of
HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
okay so he gets an order he gets an
order for 120 000 tapes he's like 120
000 oh my God who who is this so he
calls up the guy hey just want to make
sure your order is correct 120 000 or
what did you mean twelve thousand say no
no 120 000 he said I've never heard of
you before what do you do turns out the
guy is a real estate guy in Arizona but
what he started doing was he was like oh
yeah I was a real estate guy but then I
realized I could just teach people how
to make money in real estate and it's
going gangbusters and he's like what how
does this guy doing it he's like I just
ran a commercial for 30 minutes about
that I could teach people to make money
in real estate you can't do a 30 minute
commercial and he's like yeah it turns
out that there was as you like to say
and inflection and the inflection was
that in 1984 the FCC deregulated the ad
limit so they said you know before that
there was some rules you only have like
12 or 16 minutes of ads per hour of TV
they removed the limit and so now what
people could do was they could just go
to a channel and be like hey can I just
buy like your 11 pm slot for like five
grand and they're like sure and they
would just bought they was by the hour
of Television programming and they would
just run a giant commercial an
infomercial and so Jonathan hears this
and he goes to uh he goes to meet up
with his buddy this guy ranker and he's
like yo uh ranker is working at his
family's Hotel Resort at the time and
he's like you know he's kind of like the
pool and tennis guy he's just like
sitting around doing nothing and he's
like this guy ordered 120 000 tapes this
is amazing I think this might be a
better business than the tape business
like you know then you know rather than
copy the tapes why don't I copy his
business and he's like he's like all
right so what do we do he's like this
infomercial thing I think we could do
this he's like well all right so they go
they buy every book they can read on
commercials or like but there wasn't
really even the word at the time because
again the rule just got a chance there
wasn't even a category called
infomercials at the time they started
studying copywriting direct response
marketing and after a few days of just
like cramming rankers like I think we
could do this like what should we start
with they're like well
we could try the real estate thing but
neither of us know anything about real
estate nor do we like have a passion for
that let's at least for this first one
start with something we both the what's
the common ground that we both think is
like awesome like the thing we became
friends on was this kind of self
self-help self-development personal
development category so this is like
that uh sign that Cartman has when he's
like coming up with a startup idea he's
like look step one we're gonna start up
step two we're gonna scale up the step
three we're gonna bro down
or like when they're talking about
stealing the underwear they're like
steel underwear and then probably yeah
they're like well what what comes in the
middle exactly and it worked uh it
actually that actually is uh that
actually is how most startups work by
the way I think that it seems like
you're making fun of them but honestly
that's that's actually more true than
the other way so um
so they go they're like okay we can they
realize they could buy the rights to the
book Think and Grow Rich one of their
favorite books uh because it's like it's
such an old book that like the like the
copyright or whatever had laughs or some
like that they could basically buy
the rights to it for a hundred thousand
dollars so they scrape together savings
and they're like we're gonna buy this
they buy it for 100 grand in the next
three years they make 10 million dollars
in sales off that so like really awesome
for them but in the grand team of things
it turned out to be like kind of like
just a base hit compared to what they
then go on to take but what what year
did they buy the book in the 80s yeah it
was uh like early it was kind of like I
think early to mid 80s something like
that um so like 300 or 100 Grand was
like 300 Grand so it's like not a small
bet for your first time go ahead one
thing leads to another in the
infomercial that they create they get
Frank Tarkenton the NFL quarterback
they're like oh let's get anybody they
saw that had mentioned they loved the
book Think and Grow Rich they're like
hey come be a part of this infomercial
and if you the whole information on
YouTube you can go watch it in fact I
want to do a breakdown Master Class
breakdown just on this infomercial but
um you can watch the thing and what they
do is they don't tell you about the
product at the beginning they're like
you just hear Frank talking to being
like
you know I always used to feel blah blah
blah but now I'm blah blah and then
somebody else comes in and they're like
you know I was struggling blah blah and
then now I'm about and they don't tell
you what's the product that gave them
that transformation like this is the
genius of marketing is you sell this
benefit this transformation you want
people banging down your door saying
what's the pill what's the product that
gives you that right like this is the
ozempic thing how the hell are you
losing all this weight and it's like oh
I take this thing okay you know let me
have it let me have the magic pill and
so at the end of the video they say it's
thinking or Rich they do 10 million
dollars in sales over the three years
uh by the way this video on YouTube has
like 900 views uh like nobody is
studying this thing it's crazy to me
that's a video like this would have so
few views
um and they they tell the story around
the book that the richest people in the
world you know Carnegie the Rothschilds
they wanted this guy to write this and
so Carnegie commissions what's his name
Napoleon Hill to go study the the most
successful people in the world and find
out their secret and he did right and so
that's the that's how they sell this
book beautiful in the infomercial this
is an awesome infomercial they have one
guy come on who's a 24 year old Wonder
can this guy is just getting this he's
on the up and up
Tony Robbins comes on a guy named
Anthony Robbins comes on and talks about
how he how much he loves the book unpaid
by the way they're like hey will you do
this I heard you love this book he's
like I'll do it does an unpaid spot and
they're so blown away by his Charisma on
camera that they're like
we got to be in the Tony Robbins
business next so they go to Tony and
they're like hey I love your book we
want to do the same thing we didn't
think we grow rich but with your book
he's like uh okay so they're like we'll
brand it we'll figure out the
infomercial blah blah
they do it they create a program in 1988
the year I was born called personal
power and it becomes the best selling
self-help program of all time it does 20
million dollars in year one and um you
know just goes on to just how old is I'm
looking at this I'm looking at this Tony
wrap Tony Robbins has the original
infomercial on his YouTube YouTube page
for the for those personal power how old
is he here he's like 25 years older than
that that's crazy man he's got a huge
job yeah he well he he had a growth uh
pituitary growth problem which is why
all of his his hands his teeth his jaw
are also oversized he's a huge guy if
you ever seen him in person I want a
pituitary growth problem in life he and
he did it I think I think he like it was
causing him like to have secrete like 10
times more HGH than he was supposed to
and then they removed it at the right
time before he became like an actual
like nine foot over so like you know he
got the benefits of that thing it's
amazing he looks awesome man his jawline
he looks like the ultimate Chad he looks
awesome he's got Charisma of a nice guy
but like the looks of a Chad that's
that's like that's a killer dude you
know I thought that might be your take
away from all the things I just said so
I'm glad you picked up on the important
bit so
they do
um by 1990 now they're they're three
years in they're doing 36 million a year
they almost go bankrupt because the Gulf
War starts in 91 and all television
attention goes to that so the
infomercial business just sucks and they
have to basically fire everybody just to
stay alive during that year because they
were um infomercials just not converting
the war was was taking everybody's
attention so then they go on and they're
like okay here's our here's our model
and I've watched there's again this uh
the research for this was so fun there's
interviews with this guy uh if you want
to Google it is is uh
vanderbund this is the guy who who
joined really early he's been the CEO
now for like I don't know 15 years
really want to meet this guy I want to
have him on the Pod he's there's no
interviews with these guys really out
there they don't go podcasts or anything
like that but this guy vanderbund went
on
um did a talk at some school I think at
USC and they chopped up his his talk
into one minute clips and I must have
binged like 45 one minute Clips last
night of this guy I love this guy he's
got such a good uh attitude and was
saying things but he's like he's like
look here's here's our process real
simple like
uh we find the market need like how do
you find it he's like well if you see
one person with good skin and one person
with bad skin trust me there's a market
need like you see some one person with
brown teeth another person with white
teeth that's gonna be a big Market need
and I can just sell it to you by showing
before and after so that's the first
thing he's like then we find the
products and we try to license our own
them then we tie them up to a developer
or a celebrity or a story because nobody
wants to buy from an ivory tower that
says we have the solution no they want
to buy from a person who says I figured
this out I spent my life working on this
and I figured this out and uh he's like
we we marry the market need with the
marketing technique and so the market
first marketing technique they did was
that infomercial technique that drove
them for a long time and now they've
shifted to more like internet marketing
um since then and like to do the like uh
the television just the depths that they
went to so they were so early in this
they're shooting these um these things
for like you know all their brands like
they created uh proactive the acne brand
with Justin Bieber as one of the
celebrities and like these doctors as
the celebrities
um they created Principal Secret they
got this this actress Victoria Principal
and
um they were like okay we think this is
good but we don't know exactly how to
sell this product so you know what they
did they put her on QVC they were like
well that's overpay to be on QVC like is
it gonna break even probably not but at
QVC if you've ever seen how a QVC thing
goes they you can go backstage because
during QVC people are calling in to buy
and he's like basically on a like 10
second interval you can see what gets
people to buy so they did this almost as
a study to test the content so they have
her talking for an hour and they can see
what are the things she's saying that's
causing the sales board to light up and
they had they took a product that really
wasn't working they went and re-shot the
infomercial with that Intel of like what
what lines and what uh talking points
were driving the most interest and then
we shot the infomercial and now it's a
two billion dollar uh Revenue generating
product that they that they created out
of that
they create a proactive they created a
Pilates brand a brand with Cindy
Crawford they did all the stuff so they
are 100 privately held now no external
investors just guilthy and ranker
they've been doing this for 30 something
years and they do a couple billion in
revenue profitably and I was like how is
this how did they scale with the outside
revenue and then here's the funny thing
there's actually a story of like uh you
know this is a funny story so they get
this along the way they actually did
take investment so it's 100 owned now
but at one point in time they gave up 33
of the business something to this guy
Ron Perlman who himself yeah is a uh
prolific guy he owns TV networks he owns
Revlon he owns Marvel or he owned Marvel
at the time
um yeah I think he he's one of the guys
who he's hey he's one of the richest men
in America I believe I think he's like
worth like 40 or 50 like in that range
billion and he helped uh I think his
buyout of Revlon was the largest
leveraged buyout at the time and he was
kind of pioneered like the The Leverage
buyout uh I read his biography a few
years but maybe it's gone up since then
um oh I guess previously worth for a
while was huge yeah why did we go why
did it go down so much
maybe because Revlon but I think he I
don't even remember what Revlon did I
think it was like makeups but it was
like a conglomerate like it owned like
all this type of stuff but he uh he
bought it for many many billions and he
kind of pioneered The Leverage buyout
which eventually like the American
population like it was like one of those
things in the 80s where it was like uh
like uh just absolute greed and like
there's like you know it was like
Barbarians at the gate type of Ron
Perlman
um five marriages yeah there's a price
to prepaid the AI That's studying right
now that might be like I guess getting
married five times causes you to be a
billionaire no no it's correlation
you know you know how rich the guy is
he's got five pages so um
okay so they they sell it they sell them
to stake he gives them 25 million
dollars they're like beautiful and he
owns these TV networks they're like oh
great we get dirt cheap air time and we
get 25 million dollars to invest they
use that to grow like crazy pay off
these pay celebrities to like be the
endorsers like Justin Bieber and all the
stuff to do that I think they had Sydney
Crawford they had like a a makeup thing
with Cindy Crawford I think they have
one with Jennifer Lopez they had I think
with JLo yeah exactly
um eventually
Murdoch buys uh buys Ron perlman's uh
like TV networks or whatever
and then basically they're like oh we
get this stake this 37 steak and these
guthy Riker things and it just got lost
in the Murdoch like uh Empire
just uh should we just buy this back and
uh they got it back for like you know
some tiny amount so I'm like you know
they they bought they were able to buy
back on 100 of it and then I think now
like recently finally they uh I think
Goldman bought like a minority stake in
the business uh valuing it at three
billion
um
and here's how you know they're they're
really rich is a the CEO who you got who
you said van what's his name van bunt
Vander bun yeah he uh he just bought a
25 million dollar house if you just uh
whenever I hear about these people I'm
like let's see how rich they really are
you can always find out through the real
estate holdings he just bought a 25
million dollar house and then Bill
Guthrie if you if you Google him he
doesn't come up because of this business
he comes up because uh Prince and yeah
yeah they lived in his estate it's not a
house it's a state when they were like
you know homeless for a few minutes they
like they lived in his estate yeah so
and then also he owned a home that one
of the gender uh the Kylie Jenner bought
so it all comes back to the Kardashians
yeah they're they're everywhere at these
guys Peak they owned 35
000 toll-free numbers
their phone bill was 150 million dollars
a year
and she's like saying he's like yeah we
did that like did you need that he's
like we did it for attribution he's like
we needed to know what converts better
the way we did that was every time we
would try a new variation of our content
we would give it a new number so we
could just attribute which number is
getting the most calls and versus the
spend and that's how we did our
Performance Marketing in the telephone
days I thought that was pretty dope as I
like them but you're also you didn't
even mention their most successful
product that everyone who's listening
who's at least 30 years old will know
this product which one
proactive they did proactive I did yeah
proactive yeah that's the one they did
with Justin Bieber yeah well I think you
didn't put enough emphasis I needed to
pause bro yeah they did proactive which
made like a billion plus I I bought
proactive I mean everyone bought Pro did
you use it no I didn't use it but uh I
watched a bunch of those infomercials
their their information is very
entertaining like you could just watch
it as a show
um and actually it was pretty
interesting watching uh listening to
their method so he's like
um
he's like you know uh he's he he always
says the same thing he goes if you just
come to me saying X I can't I can't
change this channel fast enough you can
just tell that that's like the the
guiding principle is like you don't want
them to change the channel and it's like
everything trickles down from that one
principle so he's like it's called the
slippery slope baby you got to make them
fall down that slippery so he's like uh
these guys come in and they start
pitching me a cyber safety product and
they've been doing it for like seven
years it's uh you know the highest it
ever gross is a million dollars a year
and he's like okay so what's the product
he's like cyber safe you know like uh we
help make your your computer computers
are the new thing
um we make your computer safer so you
don't get hacked and you don't have a
virus on your computer
he's like oh man I'm if I'm watching TV
relaxing at night the last thing I want
to do is get stressed about my problem
get stressed about a problem I'm not
already stressed about uh which is like
oh now my computer's gonna get a virus
I'm gonna lose it he's like I couldn't
change the channel fast enough he's like
but before they walked out of the
meeting he goes hey I got a question for
you
you know we have this thing called need
need greed vanity that's what we try to
tap into he goes
um when you fix the computers to make
them safer does that also have any other
benefits like does it make it faster and
they're like oh yeah for sure because
you know no viruses it goes faster he
goes hmm all right come back next week
and Pitch me the fast thing they come
back and then they launch this product
called double my speed and
yeah that business that had never done
more than a million dollars in seven
years all of a sudden does 75 million
dollars a year at the time he was given
this interview which is a while back
um for double my speed and he's like you
know I just he's like I just he goes
there's too many smart people and
they're like how did you do it did you
do like Internet advertising for this
computer product he's like no we did
radio ads and it was just a radio
infomercial he's like you know I he's
like there's too many smart people
online he's like I don't want to compete
in a knife fight unless I have a gun and
he's like so we went to the radio
because really no smart people were
advertising on the radio and we could
just get a bunch of inventory for cheap
and uh we could just create content that
was better than the the current stuff on
radio and I was like man this guy's
awesome
um they were like how are they doing now
with uh infomercials not being as
relevant so he talked a little bit about
it but I don't know there's not that
much info out there um but he goes he's
so he's they were like how'd you make
this a success you know you you they're
like vent this guy whatever his name is
Vander buns's last name and they're like
uh you joined at what Revenue he's like
it was 12 million a year he's like what
is it now he's like uh like 1.7 billion
they're like oh amazing you hear that
the whole audience is like wow you know
that's amazing he's like he's like yeah
when you say it like that it sounds
crazy he's like but uh you don't see
that far he's like when you're at 12 you
could he's like what's that phrase like
you can you can't see Beyond the Wall
that's in front of you he's like when
you're at 12 all you think about is 25
and you just there's some wall between
you and 25 and then you break through
that wall and then 25 wants to get to
60. and like there's another wall to get
to 60s like you just keep doing that we
just did that over and over and over
again until you until you figure out
like you know the right thing he's like
and he's like for six years when we were
doing the infomercial thing we were so
early to that channel we were just the
best at that channel he's like honestly
we didn't learn that much during that
time he's like all the learning came in
these like he he says this funny joke
he's like um
he's like there was some year where like
infomercial started to tank the internet
started getting more popular he's like
we had 30 million people that were on a
reorder program meaning he's like our
business model is we get you interested
in a product you call up our phone we
pick up and we tell you that that
product's gonna be great for you and
that we may have some other products
that are great for you and actually you
know what if you do this right now we'll
keep sending you this product for the
rest of your life he's like that's like
the business model and he's like uh
he's like it felt like one day all 30
million people on our reorder program
called each other and we're like you
know what let's cancel this and
he's like he's like the way the world
was caving in he's like then we had to
get smart again and figure out like oh
we haven't even had to fight to win in
so long let's figure let's be smart and
let's figure this out and uh and you
know I just think these guys that these
guys have built an amazing business and
nobody really talks about them at least
in our circles
well they don't talk about it because
hey like it's not sexy I mean the money
part is sexy because like when I you
make this sound so cool but in reality
this probably looks like Workaholics you
remember that TV show Workaholics how
they're just sitting around making phone
calls that's probably what the office
looks like we're just a bunch of like
morons like sitting in this shitty
cubicle wearing like a badly fitting tie
and suit like just answering these calls
I mean that's like not that fun to do
like on a day-to-day basis I imagine
it's really fun when it's crushing it
though
um they also don't get talked about
because they've been around forever it
looks like the company was launched in
88 and before that they were doing
different stuff so it's been around for
40 years now right
um but yeah I love these guys I want to
know what they're doing with digital
because I remember like remember P90X
that's another company it's called
something Beach what's it called uh
Beachbody it so they own they're just
like Guthrie Baker but they own like
P90X style companies and they owned a
bunch of them and I remember them well
you know what they did they pivoted yeah
they to because the internet was like
coming around and they're like we have
to keep up and so now they have like a
it's almost like a Netflix style
business it's an ml subscription so
basically they change the sales model
from this direct response infomercial
model to MLM so now
they have Beachbody trainers and a
Beachbody Associates that will sell
people to join Beachbody right so they
get people to post on social media that
they've uh not only have they gotten in
shape they now work for themselves they
are independent uh and they're making
more money than they were ever working
before and if you're interested in kind
of hearing how you change how you turned
your life around like decide into the
DMS and then they basically sell you
that like you too should start selling
Beachbody programs to people around you
and you can make a lot of money and be
fit
um and dude that's the worst that that
totally like because I remember when I
was in Australia uh when I was living
there I didn't have a gym I did P90X I
did like I I did it
I thought it was awesome but when you go
the MLM route it makes me hate you yeah
it wasn't there Tony Tony Horton uh Tony
was ripped Tony Horton was ripped like
some side characters but it was like you
know whatever he'd be like the chat the
chef is here the the Russian blah blah
blah
those guys dude great program
I wonder what he looks like now is he
still yeah yeah he's still jacked I
think he has something yeah he looks
great disease he got some disease and
then kind of bounce back or something
well he still looks amazing if you
Google Tony Horton he's 65 years old now
he looks great uh so it worked
um but anyway I'm a big I like these I
like studying these companies I also
like studying them because
a lot of people in the tech startup
world are like well this doesn't
work anymore and I'm like wrong it 100
does maybe it looks a little different
we'll do this whatever slicy econ
business doing right like that's what
they're
the thing the first business I featured
which was uh you know the greed family
doing this with the Kardashians creating
a shaper brand of the Kardashians this
is no different you know the Cosmetics
brand with Kent with uh you know Kylie
Jenner there's no different than what
guthy Rinker has been doing they just
used Instagram instead of an Instagram
and Instagram celebrities instead of
Hollywood celebrities and TV it's the
same model same same thing so this one's
a great you win this one's definitely
the most interesting one
um it's incredibly fascinating one thing
that I was trying to research that I
couldn't find and I think there's a
bunch of people in our world working on
this is everything that we've discussed
it's mostly consumer products what I'm
curious is why this hasn't worked for
like a more of a B2B product so in a
weird way we aren't this but hubs yeah
bro you're like a fish being like what
is water it's like yeah we are this for
HubSpot you know that yeah but we're not
we're not the founders of the company
you know we're not we're not like oh you
know
Kylie Jenner in this case right they
basically yeah but Kylie Jenner owns 50
of that we you know I I we gotta
renegotiate one percent yeah and so I
don't own that much of HubSpot but uh I
remember the uh what was the company
that did this with the what was the
Rackspace they did it with a guy uh what
was this Robert scoble they were early
with that but I don't know if it worked
out wonderfully or what happened to that
but there's not I know there's a few
other companies so there's
um assembly Brands I worked with this
guy hunter so we launched this thing
called viral Cuts where I own part of
the company and it's like a agency that
Clips uh uh podcast Clips but it's gonna
be small it's not going to be a
multi-billion dollar company like that I
wonder why Shepherd is a good business
it's like it's a business that fits our
audience right every entrepreneur needs
to hire people if you can hire talented
people overseas for 10 times less like
this is like a no-brainer product so
Shepard was already working and then
they bring me on and now I own a piece
of that company enough of us you are the
Cindy Crawford
they looked at me a little funny when I
said it but I you know this is what I
bet and uh you know since we joined uh
you know first it was Nick Huber was
doing it with him no you're more like
the Chloe you're the you're the club
you're the Chloe man you're the Chloe oh
that's good hey plus uh
um but it's the same thing bring on kind
of like a influencer to promote a B2B
product and revenue all-time high last
month all-time high this month right
like it just keeps happening now every
single month uh by doing that and so
it's a I think it is happening more in
the B2B space and that's why it's
happening more but it's not nearly as
common and I think it will be or should
be it's a big opportunity for sure
um the thing that uh the thing is
interesting so Austin Reef tweeted this
out over the weekend I don't know if you
saw him say this he said every uh I
think he said D to C though I think he
said every like e-commerce company is
going to have a content creator that's
high more highly paid than many of the
executives so uh he says over the next
five years every DDC business will have
full-time content creators on staff the
best will be comped more than the execs
and drive more value than anyone else in
the business the math is going to make
sense to hire build and invest in
creators who can become a part of your
company narrative versus spinning off
one-off influencer campaigns the key
difference between being between a
Creator and a social media manager a
social media manager just creates a post
content a Creator is the content and of
course the best companies will be
founded by creators like happy Dad
feastables Prime Etc when people are
here Creator they think of Mr Beast or
Logan Paul I'm not referring to famous
creators just people who create content
full-time and um this is something that
we're seeing with our uh DC business but
in general I think this is I think you
just need to take out the word d2c right
darmesh had the same Insight he goes
every software company is going to have
its own Media Company why because
creating your own media is going to
bring inbound is going to bring inbound
leads
um and it's going to be more a more
efficient Channel than doing outbound
paid ads or it's going to be it and
dartmesh is sort of like that with
HubSpot I mean like uh people like
actually our most popular episodes are
darmesh uh so he's like pretty much
doing that for his own company
yeah exactly exactly um okay you want to
do you have more or you want me to do
one you want to do one more or let's do
Scott Storage yeah okay I wasn't sure if
that was in the same category but I want
to talk about it so here's another
version of
the guy behind the scenes the engine
that makes the thing work
we did it with business with d2c
products well how about music so uh this
guy's going viral recently uh for a
bunch of tick tocks because he's got an
amazing story this guy Scott Storch he
is a pretty sober now and he's like he's
like out of the key he's like left the
cave he's a producer he's a songwriter
and he's famous for a couple of things
he produced some of the biggest hits
like you know Still Dre you know the
little piano keys at the beginning is
Still Dre
that's Scott Storage was sitting on a
piano did it and Dr Dre was in a kitchen
eating a sandwich poked his head and he
goes That's it
um that's how Still Dre uh the track I
love those stories I love those stories
he did candy shop he did naughty girl he
did a bunch of songs with everybody you
can imagine Beyonce Dr Dre 50 Cent Snoop
Dogg Busta Rhymes Justin Timberlake
Chris Brown all of them
um he's amassed a Fortune of about a
hundred million dollars doing this as a
producer behind the scenes that you
didn't know about that was CR just
killing it
and he's also famous for blowing all 100
million because he got he got addicted
to two things spending and cocaine and
um and he was basically just partying
too much blowing through all his money
and now he reset so he he you know he
went to rehab got clean declared
bankruptcy basically and came back
um you know and now is is trying to
rebuild again and so this guy's story I
thought was pretty crazy what do you
know about this guy
yeah so we did a bunch of interviews
lately where he was like I was spending
two three four five million dollars a
month he was like I had houses that I
forgot about he said we had this one
house and he goes I had a five thousand
dollars worth of like glass figurines so
you were collecting like cars or shoes
he goes I collected everything that
could be collected he goes stuff I
didn't even care about I was like I had
a million dollars of Crystal figurines
it was like they I had a party and they
fell over and we just like sweeped him
up at the desk
because I had a 500 000 Crystal bottle
of perfume and the guy was like do you
even wear it he goes nah some drunk girl
at a party knocked it over and broke it
and he's like he had a four million
dollar pinky ring
if
four million dollars diamond pinky ring
and like you need to step down because
Scott Storage has it done he is a
character in Grand Theft Auto because
he's so prolific as a guy in Miami who's
like you know in in the scene there's
this one uh story uh from 2013 where he
says he spent something like a hundred
million dollars one one says 30 million
dollars once is 100 million dollars in
six months uh he's like cocaine houses
and cars yeah uh they just went hard
yeah so like I love stories like this by
the way I like it because hopefully this
will have a happy ending but I just love
people that fly close to the sun
because he dropped out of ninth grade
you know that so he dropped out of ninth
grade and you know how he made his
original like how he broke onto the
scene oh he was the keyboard guy for the
roots so he's in ninth grade he drops
out teaches himself how to play the
piano
um and he's like yeah they're like you
didn't take any courses he's like no I
mean I could afford a class he's like I
actually enrolled in one class but I
couldn't afford to get to it so I was
like ah I guess I'm just not gonna like
you know just I'll just try to sit here
he's like I would I would have a a tape
player and I'll put it on the piano and
I would hear it he's like then with one
finger I'd be like trying to recreate
what I just heard he's like and I just
did that until I could learn how to play
the keyboards like by ear he's like so
then he discovers the roots before they
were big
he joins them and he's the only he's the
white boy in The Roots and they're just
going and playing like literally on like
corners and like he's like playing in
the corner he'd go you know they'd go
down to New York and they would play for
a day and then come back to Philly and
he would just do that all the time the
roots start getting popular they get
signed but then he leaves the roots and
they're like why do you want to leave
the roots you say man I heard that's
that white boy from The Roots one too
many times and he's like they don't even
know my name he's like I'm gonna go
create my own music so he he's like I'm
gonna create my own music
through the roots he had met Dr Dre so
he goes and he hangs out Dr Dre and
Dre's like yo this guy's got talent and
so he he makes some songs with Dr Dre
and Dr Dre at this time is the biggest
producer in the world he's the most
high-end demand guy so Scott Storch
makes his 100 million dollar Fortune as
he says off the uh eating crumbs at the
end of the table so basically Dre would
get a project and he's like really picky
he's like I'm just gonna I'm not gonna
do just anything he's like so he would
just take all of Dr Dre's reject
projects and do them himself and made
100 million dollars doing that and dude
how good is Dr Dre by the way the fact
that like when when Eminem came around
you know he raps about it he's like you
walked in with a yellow jumpsuit and
you're a white guy and everyone's like
dude you can't you can't play with this
guy what do you what are you kidding
white rappers that's ridiculous if you
Google Scott Storage my wife's from Long
Island so I've gotten a bunch of Long
Island people this guy looks like
there's the Long Island Medium and then
there's Scott Storch in terms of like in
like the way that they look in terms of
stereotypes it looks like most Long
Island guy ever wearing like Ed Hardy
t-shirts and True Religion jeans and Dr
Dre like sees past that and like sees
Talent that's pretty amazing exactly and
he even says that he's like Dre's number
one skill he's like he's very
technically talented but his skill is he
can hear 10 things and he'll tell you
which one is hot and he's like we'll
play the same thing five different times
and he's like number four is the one
that sounds the best and he's like uh
Dre just has that ear for what's good
and what's hot what's next and what's
different what's unique what's singular
what's gonna stand out he's like I never
had that to that extent he's like but
you know I was good I I was able to get
good enough where I could still make you
know hundreds of hits he would get paid
a hundred grand to do a single track and
he would do 10 a week and when and you
know in his prime that's what he was
doing that's how he was making his money
so he's like dude I'm just rolling in
money here and then he stopped working
he's like I'm just gonna party now he's
like the problem was like I was spending
like I was still making money but I
stopped working three years ago and I
was just spending money like crazy and
um
yeah this guy's so here's some quotes
I'd like to read you okay
on blowing 100 million dollars quote it
happens
when you you talk about blowing 100
million I know cats that blew double
that that's the second response it
continues it can happen to anyone
I don't think you could have it anyone
and then he says and he says you know I
grew up a poor kid and then all of a
sudden I have infinite money I have no I
have infinite options and I just didn't
know how to say no um so then he uh they
were asking about like you know how do
you make a hit song he just goes like
you know in the in the real estate game
it's location location location and the
music game it's Melody Melody Melody he
goes it's Melody Melody Melody if you
can make a memorable Melody that's
that's what it takes to make a hit song
and that's what I focused on being able
to do
um so yeah this guy's Scott Storage is a
prolific character well he he'll be back
I mean I feel like if you have that
skill you can make it work uh for you
can make it work for a while right I
mean it's just it's very similar to
marketing if it's it's like if you
understand what what motivates people
and gets them to get gets them to act
whether it's dancing or buying something
you'll you'll come back have you ever
met these guys like
like they'll be guys like oh man I just
uh I got a hold of uh all these old
rookie cards uh for this baseball player
who's about to die we should like go and
buy all of them for 50 Grand and like
hold on to them for three weeks and then
we sell more I just got this old like
you know supply of like DVD players it's
only 50 Grand like they're always into
schemes like I always meet these guys
like love these schemes
every once in a while it works out and
this is like a guy Scott Stewart who's
like he'll you'll you'll meet this guy
you're like dude you're an idiot no way
that's gonna work like quit trying to
scam me this is one of those guys who's
made it work you know another guy who
did it that way was the Dollar Shave
Club guy you know it actually Dollar
Shave Club came to be a thing because he
like saw a discount on like a container
of like cheap razors and he's like we'll
just buy these oh wow yeah he's like
let's just get those cheap razors and
just figure out how to sell them I don't
know how we're gonna do it I think his
father-in-law like had a deal on like 50
000 razors and he's like uh screw it
let's just do it I've met a bunch of
these people like this
for some reason it's always a Long
Island thing by the way and uh
and Scott Storage is a is a for everyone
out there who's just scheming on these
types of like weird weird things this is
your hero
um you know what I'm talking about you
ever meet these guys and they always
have some weird hustle going down
Counting Cars I'm trying to win the
Monopoly game at McDonald's you know we
uh we're entering contests we realized
that most people don't enter contests if
there's any work so like
um my buddy Dan was amazing at this I
actually wrote him off and then later
learned this guy's a genius he freshman
year this guy lives Three Doors Down for
me
and um we're like yo we're gonna go get
food and then like we're like who are we
waiting for where's Dan and we like go
to his don't we go into his room we're
like Dan let's go man we're supposed to
we're hungry he's like oh hold on um the
deadline for this contest is in like 30
minutes I gotta I I'm out and I'm like
what contest why are you gonna take a
contest and uh like Duke is full of like
kids who play by the book and Dan never
really played by the book he was like he
had his own little book that he was
playing in and so you know he he he's
like oh this is Stride Gum he's like
Stride Gum will give you free gum for
life if you can make a commercial for
like a 20 second commercial that's like
cool for Stride Gum so he took a little
like flip cam like it wasn't even
smartphones back then he took one of
those flip cams and he basically like
filmed this commercial of himself in his
dorm room being like whatever Stride Gum
the best goddamn gum in the world
brother he's like doing this commercial
he submits it he's probably one of three
people that actually like read the fine
print submitted a did the work to submit
a commercial with that that filled in
all the thing and guess what Stride Gum
for everybody for the rest of college
right we had free stride Gump really he
won he did another one he's like um wait
what type of package did the gum come in
what's gum forever like they literally
you can just order an infinite amount
basically um like you could just keep
ordering by some some limits
um then you did another one for this
sandwich shop called Spicy Pickle
they're like hey we're renaming our
mascot and of course Dan's over there
trying to rename the mascot I'm like Dan
do you even like this restaurant he's
like no but you I want to win and I'm
like you know he's like the definition
of like play stupid games win Super
prizes but he has so much goddamn fun
doing it that you're like ah I kind of
wish I was doing this like Dan and so he
renamed so the mascot currently for
Spicy Pickle is a pickle who's a spy
called spy the letter c pickle and he's
got a business card and he's a spy that
will help you out and that's Dan Dan
created that character and then we go we
go to like the ceremony at a Spicy
Pickle headquarters uh and they're like
20 people in a circle cheering clapping
for him and they hand him a big check
that says like free sandwiches and he
wins and so he just kept doing these
things a dance from Jersey and um and I
feel like he just always had this thing
which was like I'm gonna win like I'm
gonna play these like I'm gonna find
these random edges and I'm gonna win
like I'm gonna just find these little
arbitrages and I'm gonna constantly
exploit them
dude we should do an episode on this
because have you read about the guy who
did it with Snack Pack like put pudding
cups like you remember you know like
putting okay so they they ran this
contest that says like
I forget exactly how the contest worked
but you could like uh if you pulled off
the tops of the pudding and like lick it
it like said like you won this much in
free airline miles and there was like
some contest around it but this guy did
the math where I'm just I just had to
Google it now to remember exactly but he
only had to buy I think 3 500 worth of
pudding which is like a significant
amount in terms of like how much space
it would take up in your room and he
like had all this putting and he peeled
all the packs and he was able to redeem
it for 1.2 million miles airline miles
and he like gamed the contest and
there's I like we at the hustle we used
to do this with people like gaming these
contests there's like a bunch of people
there's this community of people who go
and find these contests and they're like
all right where did they make the
mistake where if you follow this exactly
you could actually like milk it hardcore
to the extreme and there was a guy who
did this with
pudding so he basically it was it was
basically you get a thousand miles for
every 10 labels and the because the
whole thing was like for some reason
this pudding is supposed to be healthy
and so they said if you eat a lot of it
it's good for you and we're gonna reward
you by giving you a thousand miles for
every 10 labels and so the there was two
dollars a piece he figured out that he
could buy them in bulk and he's like
here's this Arbitrage where it's
profitable and he did that where he got
1.2 million miles for 3 100 wow there's
a Netflix show about this uh about about
a different version of this some guy
trying to do this with a I think he had
to buy cans of Pepsi or something like
that or Coke or something to do Airline
there's some show I haven't watched it
yet but I saw it uh show up on on uh on
Netflix
yeah then there's the McDonald's one
there's a McDonald's one too where they
where they like that was just a scam
they just they scammed it uh yes but it
is fascinating I I do like reading about
those they're always fun stories we
should one of these days we'll do an
episode of all these people who have
just gained the system we used to do
that to hustle all the time where we
would give I forget what it was it was
like one email subscriber to us was
worth ten dollars and if you referred
like 10 people we would send you a
t-shirt which was a profitable thing for
us and if you Google the hustle
affiliate contest all of these moms have
there was mostly like a stay-at-home mom
website and it's called like coupon Dash
or like some of all these websites where
it's just people who enter contests and
they're like hey look here's another one
you can win a free pair of socks if you
if you refer 50 people and it was like
referral like rings and we would get all
of these people doing this and we and we
would catch this and we're like why is
like this like a 38 year old woman named
Cindy winning all of our prizes we've
never heard of her she's won all this
stuff what's going on and you like can
figure out that they list your contest
on these websites and they game it like
crazy it's a pretty wild thing so we had
to create like a double opt-in system
because they just figured out they're
like you see them talking about like
look you don't even need to opt in your
email so you can just write like Sean
plus one at AOL.com seanplus2 aol.com
and you just win and so that's when we
had to change it but like that's how I
learned a little bit about this
underground world of like sweepstakes
they call it yeah yeah Sweepstake
hackers uh amazing all right should we
wrap it there or do we want to do any
more of these
we'll wrap it there so I think the order
of greatness the least interesting one
I think it was either mine or
the hot couple the second the perfect
couple we're gonna put the perfect
couple down there because they've been
winning at everything their whole life
yeah but it'll go perfect
yeah the perfect couple is the worst
this is
sort of like
ugly winners
yeah like the sort of like more ugly and
like you know slightly Shady you are
the higher you seem to rank on my first
million I don't know if that's
intentional or unintentional but it's
definitely definitely happens
yeah so the hot people they're your last
uh and then we'll go Robert Earl and
then the one above that is uh
oh Scott's storage is gonna go number
two Guthrie ranker number one the
juiciest
but Scott Storch is interesting too but
Guthrie raker I think there's more to
learn
all right so that's it
that's the pod
[Music]